et mon invité ce soir est considéré
comme l'un si ce n'est l'avocat le plus
puissant de france son nom est associé
aux affaires les plus retentissantes
emblématique défenseur aux demies
strauss kahn jacques chirac conseil de
total de la société générale avocat de
jérôme cahuzac et tant d'autres il est
incontournable sur les grands dossiers
du moment bonsoir et bienvenue maître
jean veil
bonjour madame mais avant de parler des
dossiers on va parler surtout ce soir
est d'abord des grands discours
ceux de votre mère simone veil ils sont
répertoriés dans ce livre préfacé par
robert badinter mes combats aux éditions
bayard les discours d'une vie que vous
avez l'idée notamment je crois avec
votre frère de rassembler sont les
éditions bayard qui nous ont demandé si
on serait d'accord pour que maman enfin
il nous et nous nous avons discuté tous
les trois et on pensait que c'était une
bonne idée que ces discours soient
réunies
le reflète assez bien me semble-t-il ce
qu'a été la carrière de maman ce qu'elle
a pu dire au couple les années sur le
droit des femmes
l'éthique la défense de l'europe un
certain nombre de problèmes que notre
dernier demi-siècle à à traverser
c'était au fond une occasion de réunir
ces textes qui qui pour certains me
paraissent importants pas simplement
celui sur l'avortement qui reste très
connu mais vrai parce que tout va et ex
aussi si on demande spontanément aux
français à nous tous quel est le
discours de simone veil qui a marqué qui
marque encore c'est celui sur
l'avortement il est dans l'histoire dans
notre mémoire collective celui ci même
s'il n'ya pas que celui ci
oui je pense que c'est un texte c'est un
texte important et je crois que beaucoup
de femmes se reconnaissent dans le
discours qui a été tenu par maman à
l'époque c'était le 26 novembre 74 et
donc déjà 42 ans est un texte qui reste
important mais je pense que beaucoup
d'autres textes sur les droits des
femmes l'égalité hommes femmes
les problèmes de l'éthique les problèmes
de la santé et puis aussi quelque chose
dont on ne parle qu'on devrait qu'on
continue à défendre qui est le la
mémoire la mémoire de la shoah
et puis la défense des deux beaucoup de
minorités notamment les réfugiés et les
migrants
beaucoup d'éléments qui garde une
actualité je crois assez criantes
ce qui frappe dans l'est dans les
discours qu'on découvre ou redécouvre
pour certains c'est quand même un style
qui est direct sans fard droite au but
avec évidemment énormément de conviction
mais un style vraiment tranchant oui je
pense que maman n'était pas un conte
orateurs par conséquent
ces discours reflète sa manière de
parler de manière assez simple
de manière très compréhensible par tout
le monde je pense que je pense que
beaucoup de beaucoup de français se
reconnaissent dans ses textes
mais ce livre il peut être j'allais dire
cruel si on le compare avec les discours
actuels parce que c'est peut-être un
style direct mais que ces palmiers à
boire oui il ya une vision il y à un
souffle je crois que je crois
qu'effectivement au travers de ses
textes mais enfin c'est toujours un peu
difficile de dire du bien de ses parents
oui mais la mcc malgré l'âge mais je je
je pense que ça garde une actualité au
fond ce qu'on peut regretter aujourd'hui
c'est quand même l'absence de grandes
voix dans notre société que ce soit en
france ou dans d'autres pays
beaucoup de beaucoup d'hommes politiques
importants au cours des deux derniers
siècles ont construit des choses
notamment je pense à l'europe qu'on voit
peu à peu se déliter dans la société
actuelle et puis le combat pour les
femmes et puis le combat beaucoup de
combats parlons du combat pour les
femmes parce que cela résonne énormément
avec ce que vous me dites l'élection de
donald trump qui est un un pro life
il l'a réaffirmé il a d'ailleurs dans
son équipe des problèmes et il va nommer
un juge de la cour suprême c'est très
important qui est anti avortement est ce
que cet acquis aujourd'hui il est
clairement menacé il a toujours été
discuté aux états unis il ya toujours eu
un combat qui ne s'est pas achevée c'est
la même chose d'ailleurs pour la peine
capitale peine de mort où on voit aux
états unis un certain nombre de gens qui
hésitent
on verra bien ce qui arrive un certain
nombre d'observateurs déclare déjà
aujourd'hui que monsieur trump a mis de
l'eau dans son vin suis pas absolument
certain
on sait que ce vernis de l'apaisement
n'est qu'un vernis justement ce discours
qu'on pense que ce qui est très je pense
que ce qui est très inquiétant c'est la
situation que nous traversons dans
laquelle la presse presque unanimes à
critiquer monsieur trump et puis quand
il a été élu à l'air de s'étonner qu'ils
mettent un peu l'eau dans son vin
mais vous même j'étais sûr que je ne
suis pas sûr que tout ça ne ne
m'entraîne pas à la fois dans d'autres
pays qui vont voter dans les semaines et
dans les mois à venir
un certain nombre de troubles où le
populisme l'emportent puisque après tout
des hommes aussi critiqué que trump
aujourd'hui apparaissent comme plutôt
rassurant au fond on peut se demander si
madame le pen ne pourrait pas en
profiter de la même manière en prose si
les propos des gens donc un caractère je
dirais temporaire à destination de leur
électorat et de manière brève
au fond c'est assez rassurant et donc
jean marie se demander si les gens ne
vont pas voter ce que vous avez dit ceux
qui critiquent donald trump s'est
souvent ce qu'on appelle alors je dis de
manière globale l'élite les élites dont
vous faites partie également oui oui
enfin je suis sûrement feu
oui sûrement oui je fais partie des
élites en tout cas les gens considèrent
que c'est le cas et vous avez critiqué
donald travaux a été surpris par son sa
victoire je pensais déjà depuis
plusieurs semaines qu'il avait des
chances d'être élu
beaucoup de gens le disent aussi comme
moi je pense que je pense que le les
critiques acerbes qui ont été prononcées
pendant des mois et des mois ont
finalement servi sa campagne
je pense qu'il faut faire attention à ce
populisme extraordinairement dangereux
alors revenant à simone veil elle est
aujourd'hui toujours depuis très
longtemps dans le coeur des français
parmi les personnalités préférées des
français
cela tient à tout ce que l'on lit tout
ce que l'on sait de son rôle de son
parcours mais aussi à la femme qu'elle
est janvier on a découvert récemment un
documentaire et des livres qui nous
raconte les coulisses mais les coulisses
d'une femme amoureuse d'une mère qui a
partagé je crois c'est 67 ans oui avec
mes parents ont été mariés pendant 67
tâches que les disparition de mon père
en 2013
c'était un couple assez assez étonnant
très complémentaires très amoureux qui
dirait pas qu'il n'y a pas eu de heurts
entre entre les deux mais au fond ils se
sont accompagnées l'un l'autre ils se
sont unis l'autre et c'était un
privilège pour leurs enfants je crois de
de grandir
à leurs côtés deux de profiter de des
leçons qui nous était donné est-ce que
l'une des leçons et on le voit bien dans
les différents portraits qui lui sont
consacrés c'est le respect qu'ils
avaient l'un l'autre d'ailleurs
l'appeler je crois que tony si je peux
me permettre
c'était le c'était son vrai prénom est
président chirac par exemple quand il me
parlait de son quand j'étais son avocat
et qui voulait parler de mes parents
disaient toujours et si on appelait tony
donc
c'était le vrai prénom de mon père donc
les ça n'est pas le plus frappant ce qui
était étonnant c'était la liberté qui
était celle de l'un et de l'autre les
compléments qu'ils apportaient est au
fond la compréhension qu'ils avaient
l'un pour l'autre le respect qu'ils
avaient là pour l'autre le respect
qu'ils avaient d'ailleurs pour leurs
enfants aussi et pour
les gens qui les approchaient y avait au
fond une grande générosité maman a
toujours été à cet égard très attentive
à écouter les gens quels qu'ils soient
quelles que puissent être leurs origines
et pas simplement les élites dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure je crois qu'elle
était et est encore très très attentive
ça c'est la femme côté colisson
découvriront l'on connaît la femme
politique mais vraiment il faut lire les
discours parce que on découvre l'étendue
des domaines finalement qu'elle a brassé
embrassez vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
évidemment la mémoire à travers la shoah
la transmission les enfants les réfugiés
les gens ont déchiqueté est ce qu'on
peut vous demander jean veil tout
simplement comment voir votre mère ne
voit pas très bien tout le monde sait
qu'elle est très fatigué
[Musique]
le des problèmes de mémoire et elle a
décidé après la mort de mon père de se
retirer de ne plus apparaître en public
enfin nous la voyons au très
régulièrement elle est chez elle et ses
enfants et ses petits-enfants dans tout
bien sûr puis la mémoire et là à travers
les discours à travers les grands actes
et à dire et jeudi la grande histoire
avec un grand h
alors je les dis introduction vous êtes
considéré comme l'avocat ou l'un des
avocats depuis puissant de france
vous n'avez rien à prouver mais est ce
que malgré tout vous restez le fils de
même si vous n'avez plus rien à prouver
oui je crois que je suis un fils à maman
d'un fils à papa mais au fond gg une
considération extrême pour pour mes deux
parents j'ai pris mon autonomie
il ya quand même plusieurs décennies
heureusement mais ce sont dans ce sont
des exemples et quand j'ai des
difficultés où je me pose des questions
je me demande ce que mes parents
auraient fait
je réfléchis un tout petit peu quelle
pourrait être la réaction et le conseil
qui me donnerait l'un ou l'autre et je
crois que c'est important pour moi c'est
ce sont des repères bien sûr le conseil
dans des grands dossiers
quand on voit la liste jean veil des de
vos clients ce sont des puissants du
monde que soit la politique le showbiz
enfin la liste officielle si je puis
dire c'est sûrement d'autres personnes
que vous défendez que nous ne
connaissons pas est-ce que vous est-ce
qu'il y a une forte une forme de
fascination par rapport à une certaine
grandeur et puis non pas une décadence
mais des problèmes qu'il pourrait avoir
je crois que c'est la chroniqueuse du
monde pascale robert diard qui avez dit
que vous êtes le conseil des puissants
foudroyé vous savez je suis le conseil
de jean qui quelquefois au milieu de
leur vie ou à la fin de leur vie sont
touchés par la justice ils sont pas
préparés ils ont vécu effectivement avec
de l'aisance matérielle du pouvoir
politique ou du pouvoir financier et ils
sont à l'étroit détruits par des
procédures judiciaires qui assez
fréquemment sont injustes c'était le cas
de dominique strauss kahn par exemple au
moment de la mnef qui a été relaxé c'est
le cas d'un certain nombre d'autres que
je ne veux pas citer ici est donc ce
sont des gens qui sont affectés par la
violence de la réaction médiatique par
la violence de ce qui est la procédure
judiciaire et qui ont besoin d'être
d'être accompagné pour traverser cette
période parce que cette période touche
aussi leurs proches familiaux
leur activité professionnelle et donc au
moment où ils sont effectivement blanchi
il est souvent trop tard quand ils sont
blanchis tous vos clients ne le semble
blanchi beaucoup le long et et non pas
par le talent de l'avocat mais ils ont
été parce que la procédure est ainsi
faite que l'on commence par accuser et
que les médias sont sans pitié sur ce
genre de choses et par conséquent ne
l'êtes pas non plus quand il s'agit de
défendre un client j'allais dire que
c'est un monde parfois et souvent cruel
vous même est-ce que vous appliquez une
méthode colonne vertébrale en tant
qu'avocat et est ce que parfois face à
d'autres avocats vous n'avez pas
supporté les méthodes des autres j'étais
arrivé parce que tout le monde est assez
injuste danser et oublient de se
regarder mais vous savez quand on
respecte un certain nombre de règles et
notamment le secret de l'instruction par
exemple existantes j'essaye de le
respecter je ne distribue pas les
dossiers dans lesquels je suis j'essaye
de protéger tout le monde et ça n'est
qu'à partir du moment où mes clients
sont attaqués que je considère qu'il est
important de prendre leur défense c'est
pas ça n'est pas nécessairement agréable
mais il faut bien protéger les gens qui
vous confient leur défense mais je
n'attaque qu en principe pas sauf dans
le cas d'injustice n'attaquez pas mais
vous est arrivé je crois vous allez me
dire si c'est le cas de vous sentir non
pas mal à l'aise mais de ne pas être
d'accord vraiment avec les méthodes d'un
avocat
c'est la sphère récent de la société
générale il paraît que vous avez quitté
en pleine audience
j'ai quitté l'audience maître koubbi
avait des méthodes que vous réprouvé
nous dit on on a le droit de critiquer
ses confrères on a le droit de
défendre son client je trouve qu'on
n'est pas obligé de traiter les
confrères avec des mots qui n'ont pas
lieu d'être dans une enceinte judiciaire
et par conséquent moi je veux bien être
critiquée je veux pas être insulté quand
on m'insulte je m'en vais je n'ai aucune
raison de rester assis à écouter
quelqu'un m'a insulté puisqu'on parle de
ce dossier jean veil à une information à
l'instant comme un communiqué sur le
site des échos
l'administration fiscale a lancé une
procédure pour récupérer tout ou partie
du crédit d'impôt dont a donc bénéficié
la société générale suite à la fraude de
jérôme qu'avait la banque avait profité
d'une restons de 2 milliards 200
millions d'euros
c'est le cas cette procédure est en
route alors premièrement le le maurice
tourner un mot péjoratif
la banque n'a fait qu'appliquer la loi
fiscale applicable à toutes les sociétés
françaises ni plus ni moins et je n'ai
pas l'intention la société générale non
plus d'ailleurs de commenter ce qui est
protégé par le secret fiscal dans l'âge
est là sans escale il voit apparemment
une entorse à mon avis je ne suis pas au
courant de ce cette lettre ou de ce
cette manifestation le site des échos
que j'ai lu aussi le site des échos
avant de venir et le site des échos ne
dis pas que cela était fait il suppute
de ce qu' il y a eu une information qui
naturellement aurait fuites donc vous me
le confirmer par non je ne confirme pas
je n'ai pas l'intention de confirmer ni
d'ailleurs d'infirmer le démentent et
annoncera peut-être demain de toute
façon cela ne change rien car en fait
l'application de la jurisprudence du
conseil d'état fera que ces sommes ne
sont pas du petit que c'est une
application pure et simple d'une loi qui
a été votée en 2008 et la loi de
finances rectificative et par conséquent
il n'y a rien de nouveau dans cette
affaire pour que le conseil d'état
considère qu' il ne peut y avoir de
responsabilité fiscale est effectivement
une absence de déduction que pour autant
qu'il y aurait eu une complicité de la
part des dirigeants de la société
générale
et cela les décisions de la cour de
cassation d'une part et même celle de la
cour d'appel du 23 septembre dernier
disque ça n'est pas le cas par
conséquent il n'y a strictement aucune
difficulté pour vous opposer à cette
information que vous ne confirmait pas
standard confirme rien dit affirmant que
je ne confirmerai pas jean veil j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure des relations entre
les avocats si on remonte un peu plus
loin à cette affaire société générale
vous avez partagé si si je puis dire le
dossier jacques chirac avec un autre
ténor du barreau était maître georges
kiejman et la cohabitation le sait
aujourd'hui n'étaient pas toujours
évidente mais kezman avait dit ceci de
vous c'est un des rares avocats
pénalistes qui connaissent le monde des
affaires
il n'est dénué ni de tact ni de coeur
alors quand on le connaît lui qui n'a
pas le compliment facile on se dit
qu'elle vaut beaucoup cette phrase
j'aime beaucoup
georges kiejman c'était un procès
difficile il est intervenu plus tard que
moi il a rejoint l'équipe et il a fait
quelque chose que j'étais absolument
incapable de faire c'est-à-dire un
magnifique une magnifique plaidoirie sur
l'homme et son destin je pense que
personne ne pouvait expliquer la
personnalité de jacques chirac et
défendre jacques chirac comme georges
kiejman l'a fait et en parlant surtout
d'un destin incroyable une vie hors
norme vraiment on invite les
téléspectateurs à lire relire ou
découvrir vraiment de nouveaux discours
ils sont là mes combats et préface par
robert badinter les discours d'une vie
chez bayer que vous avez donc
sélectionné à la demande de l'éditeur
merci jean veil d'avoir notre invité